i have something
i need to say hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be revisiting all in
enthusiast and fitness creator your girl
stephanie bettermore and you can pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating we will be discussing disordered
eating relapse so feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and if you are not already
subscribed hit that subscribe button and
follow me on tik tok and instagram
abby's kitchen so if you follow my
channel you a probably can hear that i'm
a little worse for wear my kids got me
sick as they do all the time but other
than that you also probably know that
i've discussed stephanie a few times in
the past and i am admittedly a big fan
of stephanie and her vulnerability to
share her recovery journey i know that
she's helped a lot of people who are
struggling with the idea of weight gain
or weight regain find peace with the
messiness of the process but i want to
start off this video with a public
apology when i interviewed greg ducette
about a year back or so i failed to call
him out for his mistreatment of
stephanie online this was a huge huge
missed opportunity on my part and i
really have no excuse all i can say is
that as a person with pretty severe
anxiety myself i was anxious at
about the thought of going head-to-head
with coach greg i guess i just really
wanted the fed up series to focus on the
common ground and to be additive and
supportive rather than be so
inflammatory or divisive so i wanted to
be open-minded and fair but looking back
i know that it should have been called
out so i do feel very strongly that that
was a real miss by me and i've thought
about it over and over and over again
and i really truly feel badly but my
gaffe here isn't why i'm revisiting
stephanie today so many of you have
asked me about where stephanie's at
today and her brave recounting of her
ups and downs on her own journey so
let's take a peek at how stephanie is
eating now
okay so this looks delicious and i know
steph has always been a huge pez science
cake pop protein fan uh she actually got
me obsessed with it myself but if she's
now into the elani new i feel like i
gotta try that one out too i mean
whatever brand i think this bowl is
amazing we've got fiber in the oats
we've got protein in the protein powder
collagen and the textured veggie protein
and actually i've never thought to add
tvp to basically anything never mind
like sweet cinnamon flavored oats but
it's a favorite in the plant-based space
because it has like a crumbly texture
and it packs 12 grams of protein and
four grams of fiber per quarter cup so
now i feel very interested and i
definitely am going to hit this up i
will say that this is a lower fat meal
which probably makes sense in this
unique case for stephanie since she is
gonna be training shortly after and a
high fat meal can slow down digestion
which can make training for some a
little tricky but if she wasn't training
and she did want to get a little extra
fat in this meal for satiety a little
drizzle of nut butter or a handful of
hemp hearts would definitely make an
amazing hunger crushing combo as for the
supplement drink you know i appreciate
that we didn't hear any outrageous
claims about collagen or greens powders
she just kind of made the drink and
moved on and if stephanie likes the
taste of them and they make her feel
good we love to see it amazing but a
super quick review on the data for each
as i discussed in my video right here
greens powders often are accompanied by
a lot of lofty non-evidence-based claims
and while they may be a good source of
antioxidants they're certainly not a
replacement for actual veg they have
little to no fiber and while a lot of
them are marketed as being good for gut
health they often contain ingredients
that may actually cause bloating gas and
other digestive distress symptoms just a
quick little glance at the iolani new
super green supplement and i can see
asparagus kale inulin onion garlic and
other extracts that might trigger ibs
symptoms in sensitive folks and since
pretty much all of the ingredients are
listed as proprietary blends we really
have no idea how much of any of them
you're actually going to get all we know
is that in a lot of cases they're far
below the clinical dose we know has any
evidence-based benefit as for the
collagen again i've got a video on some
of the evidence on that as well but long
story super short if we're talking
specifically about collagen for the
visible signs of aging i'm still waiting
for more quality research in this area
the most comprehensive review of the
literature on ingestible collagen
supplements looked at a pool of over 800
patients and they concluded that the
evidence to date is admittedly mixed
great
some studies found no statistically
significant improvements and others
found some benefits sometimes the
benefits were objectively measured and
other times they had to rely on patients
subjective satisfaction not to mention a
lot of the studies that do find benefits
are funded by the supplement companies
themselves so while there is a fair bit
of data none of it to date is
super great we also don't have much to
suggest that the effects of collagen
which is a protein is uniquely different
for skin than any other source of
protein since collagen gets broken down
into an amino acid called proline
hydroxyproline in the gut anyway and
we're not actually that sure if it can
even make it back specifically to the
skin intact so the jury is still out on
whether or not the collagen in the drink
is doing anything different that the
protein powder in the oats isn't doing
already but again there really wasn't
any misinformation here and there's no
harm in extra antioxidants or satiating
protein so if it works for her
it works for me
[Music]
i'm drinking a protein fit shake if i
haven't already had one earlier in the
day then i usually don't have more than
one but i'll always have one after i
work out they're my fave i have yet to
try these shakes but they do sound
really really really good really really
a bottle of milani new fit shake has 20
grams of protein 10 grams of carbs 3
grams of fiber and 140 calories so a
solid high protein lower calorie snack
and if they taste good amazing we love a
convenient snack i would say that
depending on workout intensity and how
long it ended up being before she could
sit down to a full post-workout meal she
might want to add in like a piece of
fruit for that glycogen and muscle
recovery since this is a lower carb
shake having said that she did have a
solid breakfast with almost 100 grams of
carbs shortly before so it does make
sense if this was just what her body
needed to kind of get itself to lunch
today i had to run a few errands and
then i had to come home and cook so this
is what i have for lunch i love that we
thought ahead and we knew that if we
didn't have the shake earlier we'd
probably be pretty hangry by the time we
sat down to lunch i'm hungry i have been
there so many times and that's usually
when i panic and just eat a loaf of
bread because i am too frantic to do
anything with it and this is a huge part
of intuitive eating being able to
proactively plan and nourish yourself
with food even if you're not that hungry
in the moment because you know that if
you don't do that you're gonna get
overly hungry and uncomfortable as for
the meal this looks insanely good i
don't know i must be either low-key lazy
or just drowning in motherhood and a
pandemic i don't know but i am always so
impressed when people cook a whole meal
from scratch midday for lunch i don't
really remember the last time i did that
but it was definitely before i had kids
but i love that we've got lots of
protein in the chicken fiber in the
veggies and rice and some fat in the
sauce and olive oil
[Music]
yes for sweet and savory indecision i am
there i am always there why have one
when you can have it all and her combos
are fire i always forget about english
muffins but they just hit different than
bagels or just straight up bread but
anyways we've got a little extra carbs
here for a solid mid-afternoon
pick-me-up we got fat in the avocado and
chev and lots of fiber in the avocado
and raspberries in fact raspberries and
avocado are two of the best sources of
fiber with eight and 10 grams
respectively per cup so these are two
really simple ways to up your fiber if
you're struggling to meet your 25 to 38
grams a day and if you guys are
struggling and you want a whole video on
meeting your fiber needs definitely
leave me a comment below
[Music]
we are also team frozen pizza around
here it's not delivery it's delicious i
mean i just think it's such a convenient
staple for busy weeknights and there are
so many now that are just so generally
well balanced in the case of this
barbecue chicken pizza you're getting
about 450 calories and 24 grams of
protein in half the frozen pie which i
think is pretty good in my opinion and
while this is technically low in fiber
stephanie's pre-dinner snack did have a
solid seven grams and her breakfast and
lunch together already hit 27 grams so
if she wasn't feeling any veg she
probably is already getting what her
body needs in the day but i know again
how many messages i get from folks who
struggle to meet those fiber needs so if
you want to amp up the satiety factor
here you could turn this pizza into a
hunger crushing combo like i did in my
video right here and you could just
serve it with a quickie baked salad or
even just throw on some leftover veggies
on top so for dessert i'm gonna have one
of these strawberry mochi ice cream
things these are not ice cream filled
they're just gummy mochi i sadly cannot
say i've ever gotten into moki i don't
know i'm just not into the gummy
gelatinous textures that's just me but
ice cream ice cream i can do ice cream
is kind of like the weight of my heart a
little bit so yeah i should probably
give the frozen moki a try and if it
were me i know that i would probably
need a more saturating bedtime snack
with like a solid amount of protein or
fiber but i know stephanie's appetite
has really normalized since going all in
so i do trust that this is just what she
felt like she needed or wanted before
she went to bed but if you're like me
and you got a big pre-bed appetite you
could totally turn this into a hunger
crushing combo by pairing it with like a
nut butter toast or some cottage cheese
and fruit now i also want to discuss
stephanie's recent experiences slipping
back into some old ways and i started
losing a lot of weight from simply
exploiting my lack of hunger i was
convinced that my body was still trying
to settle into its natural set weight
kept me in this mentality where my brain
associated weight loss equals good and
weight gain equals bad which i know is
wrong i was tiptoeing in very dangerous
territory i think i was subconsciously
restricting restrictive habits like
choosing the healthy option at a
restaurant skipping meals if i wasn't
hungry and feeling guilty after a high
calorie meal and i have no excuse other
than i'm human and a woman and we can be
really hard on ourselves so
first of all i just want to acknowledge
how incredibly brave i think stephanie
is as a fellow content creator i know
how much we all want these kind of
journey series to be presented as
perfectly packaged stories with poster
child happy endings but stephanie is one
of the only creators that i watch who i
feel keeps it truly real even if it's
messy as f and it sets her up for
potential criticism as she further
illuminates in this video recovery from
any restrictive behavior or mindset is
never linear it's not like a light
switch we can just so easily switch off
especially when there's a potential
anxiety trigger or disorder underneath i
know because my experience sounds
remarkably similar like stephanie i've
done a lot of work and i actually have
learned how to stop restricting food but
when i'm having a super anxious day i am
absolutely tempted to eat a lower
calorie meal or to work out extra after
a bigger meal or to judge my pooch belly
in the mirror or to you know eat ice
cream well past the point of fullness
even though i know all these things for
me i know that i've just kind of engaged
in what we call like an obsession
transfer to something else so in my case
to my sleep or insomnia and this is what
can happen when the underlying
confounder aka the anxiety isn't fully
addressed which is why i was so pleased
to hear about this the first thing i
needed to do was fix my anxiety i
decided to go to a psychiatrist and i
started taking medication for my anxiety
that i stopped weighing myself stephanie
and i have a lot in common and our
journeys have been similar in a lot of
ways so we're both starting psychiatric
meds at the same time and i'm so happy
to hear that she's feeling better and
they're helping her manage her
insecurities about weight gain and food
i also agree that weighing yourself can
be a huge trigger for a lot of us still
to this day i only weigh myself for
medical reasons because i do notice that
even with all the work i've done to
respect and love my body that
number still holds a lot of power on
vulnerable days so if i absolutely have
to do it i just make sure that i'm in a
really good supportive place
psychologically that day i guess i just
never thought of not showing my body
because throughout the entire process of
me gaining weight and when i was at my
heaviest weight i never got any
complaints on the contrary i was praised
for my bravery but now showing the exact
same thing but in a smaller body
seems to upset people so this is really
an interesting point and i'm glad that
stephanie posed this question because
it's something that i also wonder about
myself when is it triggering or not
triggering to post a body shot video
perhaps seeing like a mid size or less
tone straight sized body shots may be
less intimidating to the average woman
and therefore less likely to trigger
thoughts of restriction or the
temptation to over exercise but i also
think that the context here is the most
important thing personally i have zero
qualms about a woman wearing a crop top
just doing her thing vlogging her day
regardless of her size i think it's kind
of sad that we need to call a woman
brave for showing her body if it's not a
toned size two but on the flip side i
also don't think that we need to
chastise a woman for showing her body if
it is the product of discipline a body
is a body as a body
what i think is problematic is when said
body shots are accompanied by
instructive or prescriptive advice that
insinuates that anyone can look like
this if you eat or do or take this tick
tock wedding day videos are notorious
for this toxic format and i think we can
all agree that it needs to change so i
would love to hear from you because i am
also curious about this myself if a
creator were to eat the exact same thing
or share the exact same tips but to do
so in a different sized body would that
content affect you differently so do you
think you'd feel more triggered more
likely to engage tune out feel grossed
out or become distressful based on one
video over the other please leave me a
comment below because i'm definitely
curious so to summarize i think
stephanie has clearly done the work and
also seems to have learned that some of
us might just have to continually do the
work because die culture is so consuming
and it is so easy to get sucked back in
so i commend her for sharing her
struggles so beautifully and openly i
also think it's nice to see a mixture of
simple homemade and shortcut meals and
it's clear that stephanie has a good
sense of what feels good to her body and
her soul i don't watch a lot of youtube
for pleasure but i look forward to
seeing more honest authentic messy
content from stephanie and from other
wellness creators online and on that
note that is all that i have for you
guys today if you like this video please
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below on who or what you'd
like to see me review next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you